[Música]
es que esta semana se entregan los
premios nobel hoy se conocieron los
ganadores de medicina o fisiología
221 por sus descubrimientos sobre los
receptores de la temperatura y el tacto
ellos son david julius y arden pata
putian a los científicos utilizaron un
compuesto picante de los pimientos para
así identificar un sensor en las
terminaciones nerviosas de la piel que
responden al calor este es el primer
anuncio de la academia sueca de las
ciencias al que le siguen la física
química literatura paz y economía al
respecto a este premio nobel de física
que se entrega mañana menos del 10% de
las personas que se toman en cuenta para
poder ganar en física y química son para
mujeres científicas por ello quiero
darle la bienvenida a nuestra primera
invitada del día ella es la profesora
karen hallberg & directora doctora en
física profesora en el instituto
balseiro de bariloche investigadora
principal del conicet en el centro
autónomo atómico de bariloche en
argentina gracias profesora karen por
estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa en france 24 quiero empezar
preguntándole por qué está variedad
porque las mujeres científicas no son
tomadas en cuenta al igual que los
hombres usted que está en este mundo
está dominado por los hombres
sí que tales como la mamá muchísimas
gracias por la invitación a opinar sobre
este tema tan importante que justamente
es un tema en donde hay mucha deuda por
parte de la ciencia el equiparar a las
mujeres de la cantidad de mujeres que
hacen si es porque no hay ninguna razón
para que no haya una paridad de mujeres
y de hombres en ciencia así que todavía
y es justamente lo has dicho tener las
mujeres realmente se forman un
porcentaje muy bajo en todas las
ciencias lo ha dicho la unesco
hace dos años hay menos de 30 por ciento
de mujeres trabajando en ciencia pero
eso sí es e incluye a todas las
exigencias también a ciencias sociales
en donde hay mayor cantidad de mujeres
si uno mira las ciencias de stem que son
ciencia tecnología ingeniería y
matemática incluyendo también la ciencia
de la computación por supuesto el
porcentaje es muchísimo más bajo que eso
entonces imagínense a un porcentaje
digamos número 20 me aventuraría a decir
de mujeres trabajando y haciendo
ciencias mujeres investigadoras sociedad
realmente la sociedad como cultura
tenemos una deuda muy grande para
incluir a todas estas mujeres a muchas
jóvenes que por ahí tienen una pasión
por la ciencia pero la cultura o el
entorno me dice que no que no es para
mujeres que las mujeres podemos pensamos
de forma diferente todas esos consejos
que nos marcan y que hace mucho más
difícil no genera barreras para
involucrarnos en la ciencia profesora
karen es que mira este dato entre 1901 y
el año 2020 los noveles en ciencias es
decir en las categorías de medicina
física química y economía han premiado
un total de 710 personas de las cuales
sólo 25 han sido mujeres eso equivale al
3.5 por ciento en lo que usted nos
estaba hablando y con este dato que le
doy cómo se puede hacer y cómo están
trabajando para poder incluir estas
mujeres jóvenes para que lleguen a la
ciencia para que puedan ser ganadoras en
un futuro de un premio nobel como se
pueden incentivar no
si esos esos números realmente son
bastante preocupantes hoy se ha agregado
dos hombres más de los recientemente
galardonados 2000 chicos que ha sacado
el primer nobel o hoy de eeuu además
y justamente esos números son
preocupantes 25 mujeres de 710 pero de
710 premios es un porcentaje muy bajo
después si uno mira los premios nobel en
todas las áreas porque esos números son
solamente de las ciencias de la economía
en todas las artes también el número es
muy bajo porque son 57 mujeres y entre
800 77 hombres o sea que también es una
cuestión no solamente pertinente a la
ciencia sino también a la cultura en
general las la mujer sigue estando
marginada en muchas cuestiones de la
sociedad y el premio nobel que es una
suerte de medida de cuánto se estimula o
qué grado de madurez social digámoslo
así tienen las ciencias de distintas
partes del mundo porque yo me
aventuraría a decir también por ejemplo
si ustedes miran no sólo la cuestión de
mujeres sino la cuestión de distribución
de los premios nobel en todo el mundo
está fuertemente siempre alisado la
cantidad de premios nobel en los países
desarrollados especialmente eeuu algunos
países de europa japón y los países en
vías de desarrollo como las regiones por
ejemplo como latinoamérica estamos muy
detrás es para eso lo que dijiste
hablando de la parte regional en
latinoamérica se han dado en ciencia
sólo cinco premios nobel de 710 premios
nobel que mencionaste en total o sea que
la situación en números inclusive es
peor que si discriminamos con respecto
al género así que latinoamérica sólo
tenemos cinco premios nobel en ciencia
que son dos en química 3 en medicina y
en general si ponemos a todos los
premios nobel también son muy pocos en
latinoamérica son 16 premios nobel de
unos 900 premios o sea es que también
tenemos que analizar qué es lo que nos
está pasando como región porque estamos
tan atrás es que estamos haciendo hay
muchas muchas actividades de cínicas
instituciones especialmente por ejemplo
bueno en particular gloria li unesco
unesco está haciendo un esfuerzo enorme
por reconocer a mujeres por reconocer
las mujeres especialmente jóvenes y en
cada uno de los países también se ve que
hay esfuerzos pero hay mucho esfuerzo
sin embargo la curva
dependiente estamos con una pendiente
positiva pero es bastante baja eso eso
eso le quería decir profesora karen no
falta más inversión más desarrollo para
pues llegar a aspirar a un nobel para
que nuestra región digamos tenga más
visibilidad qué es lo que está pasando
porque está también disparidad y esa esa
desigualdad digamos sí sí sí seguramente
falta muchísima más cultura científica
en los países como a nuestra región
latinoamericana en la ciencia tiene que
pasar a tener un rol mucho más
preponderante desde lo antes de la
escuela desde el que los chicos son muy
pequeños en donde hay que enseñarles el
pensamiento crítico incluir más ciencia
en la escuela decirles a los chicos
enseñarles que el pensar no solamente
tiene que tener que ver con la ciencia
sino con la actitud frente a la vida y
eso va a cambiar mucho más la cultura
hace una cultura de pensamiento crítico
hacia una cultura de
hacia la ciencia
necesitamos necesitamos impulsar mucho
más en el aspecto de la ciencia y la
tecnología por un lado en nuestra región
latinoamericana y por otro lado la
cuestión de la mujer además con su grupo
dentro de lo que es desarrollo de la
ciencia falta mucha más inversión falta
incluir mucha más ciencia el pensamiento
crítico a todo nivel a nivel de los
gobiernos de las legislaturas hay que
cambiar la cultura y eso toma mucho
tiempo pero creo que vamos en el camino
correcto